[Musica]
prendo il messner ha definito
l'antartide un'esperienza sia di
paradiso sia d'inferno e io sono
d'accordo con lui
vedete la prima volta che sono andata in
antartide è stato molto tempo fa nel
2003 e ho raggiunto una spedizione
scientifica e insieme a loro sono
risalita sul plateau antartico sono
arrivata né veramente nel luogo più
estremo del pianeta il plateau antartico
è il luogo dove è stata registrata la
temperatura più bassa sulla terra meno
93 gradi centigradi
io non so se avete mai fatto
un'esperienza di silenzio
di solito siamo abituati a pensare al
silenzio come l'assenza di suono ma in
antartide il silenzio è veramente
un'esperienza di assenza quando si apre
il portellone dell'aereo si dispiega
questa distesa bianca piatta immobile
non ci sono i suoni ma non ci sono
nemmeno i movimenti non ci sono i colori
non ci sono nemmeno gli odori tutto è
congelato
ma è un'esperienza che di quelle che ti
cambia la vita cambia la vita perché ti
accorgi veramente che la tua attenzione
può essere catturata è sempre catturata
fuori da tanti stimoli e nel momento in
cui entra in contatto con il silenzio il
silenzio assoluto
la tua attenzione a questo punto si
sposta e cominci a sentire il battito
del tuo cuore il rumore del respiro che
entra e esce dai polmoni e si è
un'esperienza strana ma la cosa più
interessante è che poi scopri come si
sposta l'attenzione e scopre che
l'attenzione si può spostare e vi
assicuro che questo tipo di esperienza
nel servita moltissimo per le spedizioni
più ha fatto successivamente cioè quando
sono stata capo spedizione nelle
spedizioni scientifiche internazionali
che sì forse hanno a che vedere con
l'esperienza sicuramente meno
paradisiaca e diciamo che collegata
all'inferno alla parte infernale che
cosa significa fare un'esperienza di
station leader di capo spedizione in
antartide ve lo dimostro con un video ve
lo mostro qua con un video che ho fatto
in antartide
che cosa vuol dire essere alla guida di
una missione scientifica in antartide
concordia è una base di ricerca
internazionale si trova in cima alla
calotta polare siamo 4.000 metri di
altitudine e la temperatura media è di
meno 50 gradi centigradi
i progetti da realizzare sono molti
oltre al carotaggio del ghiaccio c'è il
lancio dei palloni per le misurazioni in
quota
gli strumenti che ci permettono di
campionare l'area varie altezze
organizzare le spedizioni alla costa per
studiare la ice shelf gli osservatori
astronomici gli strumenti per misurare
la gravità o quelli per studiare le
interazioni tra la terra del sole che
sono fondamentali per prevenire le
tempeste solari e poi naturalmente c'è
alla base da gestire le manutenzioni da
fare in qualsiasi condizione questo
sulla maschera il mio respiro congelato
le competenze da mettere in gioco in
questo genere di missione sono molte il
team è formato da specialisti di ogni
genere
nello stesso team ti puoi trovare un ex
militare che è stato per anni
responsabile di una sala macchine in un
sommergibile un ricercatore celebre per
essere stato un precursore nello
sviluppo dei modelli climatici l'ex
cuoco di una famosa star hollywoodiana
un incursore dell'esercito esperto in
arti marziali un ex ingegnere della
formula 1
un pilota canadese e un esploratore
insomma il team e multiculturale
multidisciplinare e soprattutto è
composto dalle personalità più disparate
l'antartide è il regno dell'incertezza
la natura è forte le nostre conoscenze
sono ancora molto limitate e la
logistica di una missione è estremamente
complessa realizzare un'impresa e prende
le decisioni nell'estrema incertezza
significa molto più che navigare a vista
perché gli imprevisti e le svolte
drammatiche sono sempre in agguato
[Musica]
[Risate]
e allora come ci si prepara a fare il
capo spedizione in antartide
beh non c'è una vera scuola ovviamente
si fanno molti corsi di addestramento
cortile del frammento in collaborazione
con le forze armate con gli incursori
con i vigili del fuoco con i medici si
imparano moltissime cose con gli alpini
anche per l'addestramento agli ambienti
estremi però non è esattamente la stessa
cosa non c'è una scuola che ti possa
insegnare che cosa significhi fare il
capo spedizione in antartide è un po
quello che succede agli imprenditori o
ai manager si fa la nba e poi però è
l'esperienza sul campo che in realtà ti
forma un grande allenatore ha definito
quali sono i cinque pilastri che un
leader deve avere e secondo lui i
pilastri della leadership sono l'essere
se stessi il sapere è quello di cui si
parla essere equi e attenzione essere è
quindi non significa sembrarlo aiutare
nei problemi e creare senso di
appartenenza nel team attraverso
l'affetto non la permanenza di lungo
periodo l'affetto sì ma non troppo ecco
vediamo un attimo questi punti con con
l'antartide essere se stessi in una base
come la base concordia quella che avete
visto in cima al plateau antartico siamo
70 80 persone che convivono in spazi
molto ristretti quindi chiaramente siamo
noi stessi anche perché le maschere dopo
pochissimo tempo cadono e quindi siamo
evidentemente noi stessi
questo è facile in antartide si però il
punto è quale me stesso devo scegliere
devo mettere in atto in questi in campo
perché vedete questa foto che alcoa
sullo schermo è una foto della l'ultima
spedizione a cui partecipato alla
spedizione alla pinza solito elizabeth
station che è una base belga e quando
siamo arrivati abbiamo trovato che la
base era stata sabotata e saccheggiata
vi confesso che la prima me stessa che è
comparsa per questa non vedevo l'ora di
andare al mare a fare yoga e facevo
belle perché mi sono messa in questa
situazione e poi però ti ricordi che se
il capo spedizione e dici no no in
realtà attorno all'altro me stesso che
dice no chiara ce la dobbiamo fare non
ce lo dobbiamo non ci dobbiamo far
abbattere da questa difficoltà dobbiamo
lavorare tutti insieme quindi si lavora
con il team sapere quello di cui si
parla
l'avete visto io devo coordinare delle
persone che sono degli specialisti nei
loro settori ovviamente io non so
praticamente niente o quasi di quello
che fanno perché sono i massimi
specialisti quindi devo riuscire a unire
la mia visione sistemica con le varie
specialità cercando di tirare fuori il
meglio da ciascuno di loro è riuscire a
integrare le diverse visioni e vi
assicuro che non è semplicissimo quando
ci sono soprattutto le tensioni e le
attività in emergenza e in urgenza
essere equi e attenzione essere a qui
non è sembrarlo beh questa è una foto
della nave alla costa che scarica tutti
i nostri materiali tra cui anche il
carburante essere equi e molto difficile
nel momento in cui succedono degli
imprevisti e la pianificazione salta
come l'anno in cui la nostra nave è
stata bloccata da un enorme iceberg un
enorme pezzo di ghiaccio che si era
interposto tra la il punto in cui stava
la nostra nave e la base dove doveva
scaricare il carburante e belli li
essere equi quando devi decidere qual è
la priorità da dare a un progetto ea un
altro beh diventa molto difficile eppure
devi riuscire a essere equo
pur non essendo equo entrambe e poi
questi due punti li ha messi insieme
aiutare nei problemi e creare senso di
appartenenza attraverso l'affetto li ho
messi insieme perché sono donna
tipicamente quando racconto
dell'antartide mi dicono bene ma per noi
il dialogo noi donne siamo più per il
dialogo la cura la facilitazione lo
sviluppo dei team è si vero quindi in un
certo senso siamo avvantaggiate e nello
stesso tempo però poi bisogna prendere
la decisione nel momento in cui devi
dire no devi dire questa attività si fa
questa attività non si fa sei solo se il
capo spedizione devi decidere tu
ovviamente dopo aver sentito tutte le
varie idee dei membri del tuo team e
quindi sia ancora riuscire a conciliare
questi due aspetti
credo che la leadership più che modello
si ha il coraggio di abitare la
molteplicità la molteplicità che abita
in noi
quindi i vari noi e la molteplicità che
abita fuori e questo credo che sia un
tema abbastanza urgente perché quello
che sto quello su cui sto lavorando in
questo momento è portare nelle
organizzazioni nelle imprese nelle
organizzazioni umane un po di
quell'esperienza dell'antartide perché
l'antartide è già qui perché
l'innovazione è estremo e quindi avere a
che fare con l'estremo vuol dire avere a
che fare con la molteplicità e vuol dire
saperla navigare saperla gestire e
quello su cui lavoro è main set e
attenzione ma in set per me è
l'esperienza corpo mente è l'uso che
facciamo della nostra energia e l'uso
che facciamo incarnato della nostra
energia e quindi sviluppo dei progetti
si tratta di qualche modo di spostare
l'attenzione all energia all esperienza
corpo mente dai problemi ai vincoli
dagli schemi mentali che di solito ci
abitano verso un atteggiamento più
strategico e cos'è un atteggiamento
strategico se no non uso più consapevole
della nostra energia e chiaramente non è
facile bisogna farne un'esperienza
incarnata ecco un esempio un esempio di
cambio di prospettive oppure
stati simultanee che si devono mettere
in atto per esempio in antartide
dobbiamo avere un occhio sul presente e
quindi sviluppare il piano e cercare di
implementare tutte le attività che
abbiamo in mente nello stesso tempo
avere un occhio sul futuro perché
accadono gli imprevisti continuamente e
quindi dobbiamo saper prevedere saper
intervenire nel momento in cui avvengono
gli imprevisti e qual è la differenza
dalla vita che facciamo tutti i giorni
dalla vita che fanno i manager
imprenditori devono prosperare nel
presente e sviluppare l'innovazione per
il futuro
ecco questo tipo di esperienze incarnate
e di attività credo che siano importanti
e che possono anche dare
un senso di cambiamento ed essere molto
importanti per le persone con cui
lavoriamo come per esempio è stato
importante per me l'esperienza di
assenza che per me è stato l'inizio di
un viaggio verso l'essenza all'inizio di
un viaggio verso la consapevolezza del
di come la mia attenzione può essere
catturata fuori dalle molteplici
attività e che fa benissimo ci sono
attività bellissime ma ci sono attività
che forse non sono così importanti per
me quindi uno su consapevole della
nostra energia credo che sia un qualcosa
che ci possiamo augurare come esseri
umani in generale perché magari lo
sappiamo a volte lo dimentichiamo
energia che utilizziamo nel presente è
quella che costruisce nostro futuro per
cui vi auguro tutti un uso consapevole
della vostra energia
[Applauso]
[Musica]